what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 update video I just received some
brand new information about some huge
scenes that is going to take place in
episodes 1 into this season and that
involves our favorite maester and
training Samwell Tarly as we get closer
to the premiere of episode 1 more and
more information about the season
continues to come out if you have been
staying up-to-date with everything then
you should know that the names of the
first three episodes were just released
recently and those first three episodes
also came with a short description
briefly stating what the episodes would
be about but today there happens to be
an extended version of the description
for episodes 1 & 2 which should be
pretty significant scenes to start the
season off with a subscriber of this
channel in a friend of mine from the
talkin Thrones Facebook page sent me
some new information earlier that shows
the new descriptions for episode 1 & 2
his name is Tim and he lives over in
Belgium and thankfully he was kind
enough to translate this for me as well
because it is written in the Dutch
language tim says the description for
episode 1 says john organizes the
defenses in the north
Cersei tries to even the odds Daenerys
comes home and Samwell Tarly discovers
some crucial information this is very
interesting now we already knew the
stuff about John Cersei and Dany
but this description for Samwell seems
in episode 1 or brand new and this has
me very excited because now we know Sam
is going to make some breakthroughs in
the very first episode but the big
question is what the hell could he be
discovering already let's come back to
this later though because I want to read
the new description for episode 2
because it's even more interesting and
exciting than this one episode 2 says
Daenerys receives an unexpected visitor
John faces a revolt
Tyrion plans the conquest of Westeros
and Sam is going to risk his life and
career in the second episode this season
I have a good idea of what this may be
but let's go back to the first
description real quick what crucial
information do you think Sam could be
discovering this fast we know from the
official release photos from HBO that
Gilly is reading a page straight out of
world of Ice and Fire more or less about
a Zora hi but since it said Sam
discovers it I'm thinking it may be
something else could say and I found
some new and crucial information about
how to defeat the White Walkers there is
a popular theory that says Sam will also
find some information regarding the true
parentage of Jon Snow
maybe he comes across some kind of
document or certificate about Rhaegar
and Lyanna in the birth of their baby
boy Jon Snow was saying being at the
Citadel surrounded by this world's
history I think the possibilities are
endless Sam may even find something out
that has to do with Valyrian steel he
may find out the secrets of how to make
Valyrian steel from scratch but Sam
could come across the ingredients and
magic that is needed to make it out of
any steel which would obviously be a
huge find considering the long night is
upon us
but it could also have something to do
with greyscale and when I read the
description of episode 2 it does seem
like he will help Jorah very early this
season episode 2 says sam risks his life
and career that could mean he is working
on Jorah and his deadly infectious
disease greyscale maybe they don't want
him treating someone with greyscale this
early into his training but if Marwin
the mage ends up being there and being
Sam's mentor then they may set up their
own little lab to do whatever the hell
they want they might do their own
experiments off the clock I should say
there was a new maester that was casted
months ago in the report said that this
maester would be in five episodes or
five scenes this season most likely was
Sam at the Citadel and the big rumor or
theory is it's going to be Marwan Marwan
is one of the maesters from the books an
arch maester of the Citadel and he is
famous for doing these kind of
experiments he knows all about the human
anatomy and by looking at some of the
HBO photos that they released it does
look like Sam is going to be working
with him there does appear to be a human
brain on the scale back there I think
these two will most likely be the ones
to work on and treat Jorah Mormont and
his greyscale if you actually look over
at the wall look at the texture of that
wall and do you see the candleholder
that's in the middle of the wall look
how closely it looks to the wall from
the trailer when we see the man's arm
sticking out of the cell you can also
see a candleholder on the wall on this
photo - these two shots may be from the
same room Sam may even be looking over
at Jorah as he
sticking his arm out of the cell by the
local and Sam's face it seems like
something definitely has his attention
personally i 100% believe sam will work
on Jorah this year and i think this may
be what is going on when the description
for episode 2 says sam is going to risk
his career in life Sam is going to be a
very busy man this season and he's going
to start uncovering the answers that is
needed to make it out of this long night
alive the producer said this season
would move at breakneck speeds and I
don't think they were kidding
their season it's going to get the ball
rolling right out of the gate in episode
1 was Sam finding some crucial
information my excitement for Sam story
arc this year just went up a couple
levels now but let me know what you all
think about this stuff though I wanted
to keep this video brief because I'm
actually working on something pretty
epic as we speak that's going to be
released on this channel Friday so I
hope you all enjoyed this quick update
video now we have even more to look
forward to this Sunday when the premiere
of Episode one comes on comment down
below and let me know what you think it
means when it says Sam find some crucial
information and also let me know what
you think it means when it says Sam puts
his life and career at risk I'm curious
to see what you all come up with I think
the second episode will involve Jorah
Mormont for sure thanks for stopping by
everyone I really appreciate you
checking out this video also keep your
eyes open this Friday because like I
said I have something pretty damn big
into making that I think all of you will
love have a good day and I'll see you
all down in the comment section bye